[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen in allen
schönen dass sie dabei sind wie auch
norbert lehmann für den sparzwang schön
und antwort von mir und das sind die
nachrichten themen von heute
entlastungen in schweren zeiten bei
seiner sommerpressekonferenz verspricht
der kanzler weitere hilfen für die
menschen die wie er sagt ganz wenig
haben
beweis will davon der krim bei
explosionen sind dort mindestens sieben
russische jets zerstört worden russland
hatte das abgestritten und
kaum noch wasser unterm kiel wegen der
dürre stock der rohstoff transport auf
dem rhein eine gefahr auch für die
wirtschaft
wir haben ernste zeiten die uns noch
viel abverlangen werden sagt olaf scholz
heute auf seiner ersten
sommerpressekonferenz als bundeskanzler
er verspricht neue entlastungen und dass
niemand allein gelassen werde deswegen
werde es auch zu keinen unruhen kommen
aus berlin berichtet britta spiekermann
die probleme scheinen übermächtig
ukraine krieg gaskrise und auch noch
corinna scholz wirkt gelassen
demonstriert alles im griff you'll never
walk alone ist sein kernsatz niemand
werde alleingelassen
diejenigen die ganz wenig haben und
deshalb haben wir gesagt wir wollen beim
wohngeld was machen sein bürgergeld und
sind dabei intensiv diese in form
vorzubereiten scholz spricht viel über
milliardenschwere entlastungspaket sie
seien auf dem weg und schon im september
sichtbar für die bevölkerung auf dem
gehaltszettel der soziale frieden werde
halten und nun werde es nicht geben weil
der sozialstaat ab federer diese
botschaft klar ist bin ich ganz sicher
dass wir uns unterhaken und dass das die
deutsche antwort auf eine solche
herausforderung sein wird
eine so genannte über gewinn steuer die
energiekonzerne zur kasse bitten würde
soll es nicht geben auch nicht die
erhöhung des spitzensteuersatzes
wir haben uns darauf verständigt keine
einkommenssteuer erhöhung zu machen für
spitzenverdiener
das stand im spd-wahlprogramm ich glaub
an dem der grünen aber nicht
auch der comex finanzskandal der
hamburger warburg bank spielt eine rolle
scholz war zu dieser zeit erster
bürgermeister der hansestadt auch heute
bestreitet der jegliche verwicklung und
maßgebliche kontakte zweieinhalb jahre
unglaublich viele anhörung unglaublich
viele akten haben nur ein ergebnis
gebracht es gibt keine erkenntnisse
darüber dass es eine politische
beeinflussung gegeben hat zum ukraine
krieg selbst betont scholz deutschland
sei keineswegs zurückhaltend bei
waffenlieferungen
seine regierung werde das land weiter
unterstützen
das was jetzt stattfinden muss und das
ist die aufgabe die es jetzt geht das
ist doch dass die russland einsieht dass
es sich verständigen muss mit der
ukraine und dass das nicht hinauslaufen
kann auf einen diktat frieden die korona
politik so gut wie kein thema der
bundestag werde im september ein neues
gesetz beschließen daraus spricht wohl
die hoffnung dass sich der aktuelle
streit über maßnahmen verflüchtigt
unterleib energy in berlin wer den
kanzler so zuhört könnte meinen die
regierung habe alles im griff
ja viel platz für selbstkritik war da
tatsächlich nicht eher schon für
selbstbestätigung
er hat die gelegenheit vor allem dazu
genutzt ein signal auszusenden nämlich
das signal ich bleibe auf kurs sowohl
bei den inhalten als auch beim
regierungsstil und vor allem letzteres
ist interessant weil es ja in seiner
koalition schon brodelt die spannungen
zwischen fdp und grünen die sind hier in
berlin mit händen zu greifen nicht nur
bei den themen steuerpolitik oder akw
verlängerung und da könnte man
vielleicht erwarten dass der kanzler mal
ein machtwort spricht das wird er nicht
tun das hat er heute noch einmal
klargemacht dass das nicht sein stil ist
er setzt weiter auf die verständigung
aller koalitionsvertrag das hat er auch
noch einmal klar gemacht und er ist
zuversichtlich dass das für die
kommenden zehn jahre reicht also keine
großen überraschungen da das war ein
typischer scholz könnte man heute sagen
und ein stilwechsel ist nicht zu
erwarten
einschätzungen von chuck unterleib
energy vielen dank
weil russland seine gaslieferungen
gedrosselt hat müssen energieunternehmen
den rohstoff teuer anderswo kaufen ab
oktober ermöglicht ihnen die regierung
ihre höheren kosten mit der gas umlage
an alle gaskunden weiterzugeben rwe
kündigte jetzt an diese möglichkeit
nicht zu nutzen was steckt dahinter
frank bethmann na ja vor allem dass rwe
derzeit satte gewinne macht vor zinsen
und steuern waren das im ersten halbjahr
2,8 milliarden euro einen rekord die
essener profitieren dabei von der
energiekrise und den gestiegenen preisen
rwe verdienen vor allem mit seinen
erneuerbaren energien mit dem betreiben
von wind- und solarparks die unerwartet
hohen gewinne fallen rwe quasi in den
schoß der konzern kann mit seinen solar
und windkraftanlagen günstiger strom
erzeugen als gaskraftwerke darf seinen
günstig erzeugten strom aber abrechnen
zu den dramatisch gestiegenen kosten
eben dieser gaskraftwerke klingt
irgendwie paradox ist aber letztendlich
ein gewinn beschleuniger und das
wiederum wirft die frage auf muster
nicht doch der staat eingreifen
abschöpfen mit einer über gewinnsteuern
dagegen rwe heute nicht darauf ein man
wolle die gewinne in die energiewende
investieren und verzichte eben auf diese
gas umlage die diskussion über eine über
gewinnen steuer ist damit aber ganz
sicher nicht vom tisch danke frankfurt
gerne
schauen wir in die ukraine präsident
zielinski hat seinen landsleuten immer
wieder versprochen die krim werde
zurückerobert neue satellitenaufnahmen
scheinen nun einen angriff auf eine
russische militärbasis auf der halbinsel
zu belegen moskau gibt zu dass es dort
explosionen gegeben hat spricht aber von
einem unfall pablo de la la
die satellitenbilder einer us-firma
zeigen das ausmass der schweren
explosionen auf dem russischen
luftwaffenstützpunkt sacchi wurden dabei
offenbar mindestens sieben
kampfflugzeuge zerstört noch immer ist
die frage unbeantwortet was genau die
detonation ausgelöst hat und wer dafür
verantwortlich ist moskau spielt die
situation herunter bestreitet dass
kampfjets zerstört wurden lediglich
munition habe feuer gefangen entfacht
von einem unachtsamen wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
auch heute gab es wieder explosionen
unter anderem in dornbach in donetzk
soll eine brauerei getroffen und dabei
ammoniak ausgetreten sein berichte über
gefechte gibt es auch aus bach mut im
osten des landes und aus nicole im süden
120 raketen sollen in der gegend
eingeschlagen seien die knapp 80
kilometer von paris entfernt ist die
gegend um das größte atomkraftwerk
europas befindet sich seit tagen unter
beschuss präsident sident ski warnt vor
einem neuen tschernobyl
jahrelang hat niemand geglaubt dass
europa wieder von einem unglück in einem
atomkraftwerk bedroht werden würde nicht
weil jemand die sicherheitsvorkehrungen
nicht einhalten würde sondern weil ein
land ist als terror werkzeug benutzen
würde so die russland ist jetzt tut mit
der gefahr einer nuklearen katastrophe
beschäftigt sich am abend auch der
un-sicherheitsrat in new york bei einer
krisensitzung
etwa 60 kilometer entfernt von dem
atomkraftwerk in sapporo cia ist anne
prüfe uns alle wie gefährlich ist die
situation
ja die lage ist durchaus
besorgniserregend es hat ja mehrere
explosionen heute nachmittag auf dem
gelände dieses atomkraftwerks gegeben
von vier sprich die ukrainische
energiebehörde ein pumpwerk sei
beschädigt worden in der nähe einer
strahlungsquelle hieß es es seien auch
sensoren zur strahlung messen
ausgefallen das klingt nicht besonders
gut wir selbst waren heute in nico popp
der stadt die einem bericht angesprochen
wurde vier kilometer von dem
atomkraftwerk entfernt auf der anderen
seite des flusses nico paul wird dauernd
beschossen auch das wurde schon gesagt
aber die sorge der menschen dort ist
eine andere nämlich die vor einer
atomaren katastrophe in direkter
nachbarschaft die stadt verteilt
jod-tabletten es gibt auch
evakuierungspläne aber sollte sich
wirklich ein großer unfall auf dem
gelände dieses atomkraftwerk
zu tragen dann sind nicht nur die
menschen in nico paul in allerhöchster
gefahr
vielen dank für diese informationen live
aus la push ja meine pulver das wie groß
ist das nukleare risiko für deutschland
welche maßnahmen werden im notfall
ergriffen in unserer zdf heute app gibt
ein experte für strahlenschutz antworten
auf die wichtigsten fragen
hierzulande hinterlässt der trockene
sommer immer deutlichere spuren seen und
flüsse schrumpfen vom rhein ist an
vielen stellen wenig übrig morgen sinkt
der pegelstand in koblenz wohl unter die
marke von 40 zentimetern tendenz weiter
fallend bisherige rekordwert
25 cm im jahr 2018 das trifft auch
rohstoff transporte zwar ist die
fahrrinne tiefer eine handbreit unter
wasser eine handbreit wasser unterm kiel
reicht aber vielen schiffen nicht an
seinem stern
der sonst so mächtige rein gezeichnet
von der trockenheit bingen rheinland
pfalz hier ist der fluss in großen
teilen zur kiesbank geworden viel zu
wenig wasser die wasserstraße immer
flacher immer kleiner frachter sind
unterwegs aber sie haben nur noch sehr
wenig geladen die schifffahrt fährt mit
deutlich reduzierter transportmenge das
ist gegenüber den normalen wasserständen
sind wir gut bei der hälfte der
tragfähigkeit der lade menge bei den
schiffen angekommen die hälfte der
ladung oder weniger mehr geht nicht der
rhein ist nicht mehr tief genug heißt
extrem viel weniger chemikalien diesel
kohle kommen an bei den unternehmen und
das jetzt wo die nachfrage etwa nach
kohle wegen russlands krieg drastisch
steigt das treibt schon wieder die
preise und die sorgen wenn sich die
situation noch weiter zuspitzt werden
die transportpreise noch weiter
explodieren
momentan haben wir durch das
niedrigwasser schon erhöhte preise
dadurch dass die binnenschiffe ja nicht
so viel kapazität aufnehmen müssen und
häufiger fahren müssen wir brauchen mehr
transporte zum beispiel werden die
tankstellen auf mineralöle
wahrscheinlich verzichten müssen die
über das binnenschiff angeliefert werden
und unsere unternehmen natürlich auf die
auf die rohstoffe die sie dringend
brauchen
besonders drängt das thema jetzt etwa
hier in kauf in der nähe von bingen eine
entscheidende engstelle am rhein eine
der wichtigsten wasserstraßen europas
verliert immer mehr an kraft und
christel haas steht jetzt im flussbett
des rheins beibringen und es wundert ein
dass er überhaupt noch große schiffe
fahren können christel
na ja normalerweise würde mir das wasser
hier ungefähr bis zum kopf oder höher
stehen aber jetzt sind hier nur kiesel
die schiffe fahren trotzdem in ihrer
rede aber alle gucken natürlich gebannt
auf die pegel denn jeder schaefer muss
für sich selbst entscheiden ob er noch
fahren kann oder nicht und das jeden tag
und je niedriger die pegelstände desto
weniger schiffe werden das wohl können
auf die frage ob man die transporte denn
nicht auf die straße oder auf die
schiene verlagern könnten antworten die
industriebetriebe mit einem klaren nein
ein zuviel verkehr zu viele baustellen
zu viel verzögerung bei der bahn und es
fehle massiv an lkw fahrern sorgen und
bangen und hoffen um den rhein geht also
weiter dankeschön crystal hat
die dürre verursacht europaweit enorme
schäden die waldbrände sind
wirtschaftlich und ökologisch ein drama
in portugal etwa im zentrum des landes
in einem der größten naturparks lodern
gleich mehrere feuer besonders heftig
ist es aktuell im südwesten frankreichs
wieder bordeaux wo es erst im juli
heftig gebrannt hatte anna wiesbeck
die flammen sind zurück und fressen sich
immer weiter durch den wald wieder hier
in der gironde im südwesten frankreichs
wieder müssen die menschen schlagartig
ihre häuser verlassen
für die kinder tun wir so als seien wir
nicht besorgt aber ja natürlich sind wir
sehr besorgt wir wissen nicht wann wir
zurückkommen können die waldbrände vom
juli waren unter kontrolle jetzt ist das
feuer neu entfacht
an insgesamt acht orten in frankreich
kämpfen die einsatzkräfte rund um die
uhr gegen die flammen nach einem
hilferuf der regierung ist unterstützung
aus ganz europa auf dem weg
die europäische kommission hat
angekündigt auch löschflugzeuge zu
mobilisieren also kräfte um frankreich
zu unterstützen
es werden auch einsatzkräfte aus
deutschland polen österreich und
rumänien mobilisiert
auch in portugal immer wieder neue
waldbrände im naturpark serra dass
streller sind schon über 10.000 hektar
abgebrannt es ist vor allem die
kombination aus wind trockenheit und
hitze die es den bränden in
südwesteuropa ermöglicht sich so schnell
und weit auszubreiten ob und wo auch
brandstiftung eine rolle spielt wird
ermittelt
und an einer weiteren stelle zeigen sich
die verheerenden folgen der hitze die
gletscher der alpen schmelzen im
rekordtempo von deutschlands fünf
verbliebenen gletschern so warnen
experten könnte einer schon in diesem
jahr verschwinden
der südliche schneeferner auf der
zugspitze
neben den temperaturen liegt das am
sahara staub aus dem frühjahr er nimmt
vielmehr hitze auf als eine oberfläche
aus eis schnee
jetzt zum tod eines 16-jährigen der
viele fragen aufwirft am montag hatte
ein polizist in dortmund den jungen
senegalesen mit einer maschinenpistole
in gesicht bauch arm und schulter
getroffen innenminister reul versprach
heute hundertprozentige aufklärung und
warnte zugleich vor
vorverurteilungen heiko rams hat details
dortmund nordstadt gestern abend den
zweiten tag in folge demonstrieren
menschen gegen angebliche polizeigewalt
auslöser für die proteste war der tod
des flüchtlings er wurde von fünf
polizeikugeln getroffen nachdem er mit
einem messer auf die beamten losgegangen
sein soll zuvor soll der jugendliche mit
selbstmord gedroht haben ein
gesprächsversuch zwischen den polizisten
und millionen sei gescheitert zu der
nrw- innenminister hat man mit reizgas
versucht ihn außer gefecht zu setzen
daraufhin haben die polizisten mit
lasergeräten versucht ihn zu fixieren
und auch außer gefecht zu setzen das hat
nicht funktioniert es mit bedrohlich und
dann hat der polizist dafür zuständig
ist aus einer entfernung die schüsse
abgegeben der jugendliche starb wenig
später im krankenhaus noch am vortag
wurde er wegen psychischer probleme in
einer klinik behandelt elf polizeibeamte
standen den jugendlichen bei der
auseinandersetzung gegenüber ob der
flüchtlinge aus dem senegal ausreichend
deutsch verstanden hat ist unklar
dann bedeutet das aber auch dass ich
mich erst mal zurücknehmen muss als
polizei und versuchen muss die lage neu
zu bewerten und nur dann wenn eine
wirklich konkrete gefahr besteht in dem
ein konkrete an mit angriff unmittelbar
bevorsteht dann kann ich zur schusswaffe
greifen und hier habe ich so meine
zweifel
aufgeklärt werden muss auch warum mit
einer maschinenpistole geschossen wurde
die staatsanwaltschaft dortmund hat die
ermittlungen aufgenommen
der marburger bund schlägt alarm
angesichts der arbeitsbelastung in
deutschen krankenhäusern laut einer
mitgliederbefragung denkt ein viertel
der angestellten ärztinnen und ärzte
darüber nach den beruf aufzugeben einer
der hauptgründe die vielen überstunden
57 prozent der befragten gaben an 49
oder mehr stunden pro woche zu arbeiten
außerdem bemängeln die mediziner unter
anderem das viel zeit für die verwaltung
draufgeht
wieder ein schwerer unfall in einem
freizeitpark im legoland bei günzburg
wurden mehr als 30 menschen verletzt
zwei davon schwer ein achterbahn zug
habe im einstiegsbereich stark
abgebremst der folgende sei aufgefahren
erklärte ein polizeisprecher wie es dazu
kommen konnte ist noch unklar
erst am wochenende war im
rheinland-pfälzischen kloppen eine frau
aus einer achterbahn gestürzt und
gestorben
und jetzt fußball norbert die eintracht
hat gestern nicht auftrumpfen
dafür dann die königlichen doch nur
nummer zu groß für die eintracht 0 2
gegen den champions league gewinner aber
das fühlte sich dann doch anders an als
die 1 zu 6 klatsche gegen die bayern
letzten freitag diesmal eine niederlage
mit erhobenem haupt
applaus für den verlierer das legendäre
real madrid steht spalier für die
eintracht in der 37 minute bringen david
alaba real in führung
die entscheidung dann in der zweiten
halbzeit das die frankfurter abwehr
bands immer nicht attackiert dafür aber
der wind habe die sicht versperrt es ist
für die eintracht ein übungsspiel für
die bevorstehende champions league
deswegen
haben wir gesehen dass es für diesen
level für diesen gegner noch nicht recht
real madrid holte in helsinki den
zusammengenommen 28 internationalen
titel
erste wettkampftag bei den european
championships in münchen den
europameisterschaften in neuen
sportarten unter anderem im rudern ja
und da hat lokalmatador und
titelverteidiger oliver zeidler meiner
das halbfinale erreicht allerdings nach
anfänglichen schwierigkeiten im ziel
haderte oliver zeidler in wenig denn am
start hatte er als zweiter von oben arge
probleme bekam keinen druck auf das
ruderblatt verlor viele sekunden auf die
konkurrenz aber zeitler holte auf und
lag im ziel deutlich von samstag hat er
sein halbfinale und der männer achter
schon das finale als zweitschnellste des
vorlaufs zog das deutsche paradeboot in
den endlauf ein auch heute wieder nicht
zu schlagen die briten den sprung ins
team finale am samstag schaffte auch die
deutsche politik der frauen trotz dieser
schrecksekunde von sarah voss am balken
die aber weiter tonen konnte am
stufenbarren blieben elisabeth seitz und
kim bui weitestgehend fehlerfreie und
haben dadurch beste chancen auch im
einzel finale um medaillen zu tonnen
und die entscheidung im mehrkampf einzel
jetzt bei uns zu sehen im livestream auf
sport studio
die sehnsucht nach einer frischen brise
ist derzeit groß bei der hanse sail in
rostock gibt es seit heute nicht nur
reichlich traditionsschiffe zu sehen wer
seefest ist kann die segel hissen und
mit war aber auch alle anderen kommen
auf ihre kosten bei einer mischung aus
volksfest
und gefeiert wird ohne einschränkungen
ohne tests und maske aber mit viel
gesunde meeresluft
das heiße sommerwetter hat auch schöne
seiten sternschnuppen zum beispiel die
zeitgleich katja oliver marietta slomka
begrüßt sie um 10 18 im heute-journal
und wir sind morgen wieder da einen
schönen abend ihnen und alles gute
[Musik]
guten abend da eine sternschnuppe eine
von vielleicht 100 pro stunde die sie
derzeit nacht sehen kann verantwortlich
dafür ist der komet swift-tuttle
entdeckt vor 160 jahren der saust um die
sonne und verliert kleines staub und
gesteins teilchen immer im august kreuzt
die erde auf ihrer umlaufbahn diese
kosmische partikelwolke treffen die
teilchen auf unsere lufthülle beginnt
diese zu leuchten von der erde aus
gesehen passiert das in der nähe des
sternbildes perseus daher heißen diese
sternschnuppen per sie
höhepunkt des sternschnuppen regens ist
wohl samstagfrüh 3 uhr wolkenlos wird es
dass er oft seien allerdings könnte der
mond stören
denn morgen früh um 3 uhr 34 ist
vollmond bis zum frühen morgen sinken
die temperaturen auf 18 grad am rhein
und bis 10 grad am alpenrand auch morgen
wird wieder sehr sonnig ganz vereinzelt
könnte es in ostbayern am nachmittag
vielleicht für ein gewitter reichen die
temperaturen erreichen 23 bis 34 grad
und die wochenendtage werden sonnig und
heiß sein aber zum montag dreht der wind
auf südwest und es wird schwülwarm und
gewittrig genannt